luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to the lay hyalpan show it is powered by icon plus
capital sponsored by blockfi you can get up to 250
when you sign up some amazing um interest rates so
i've left um a link for you in the comments and
in the description and this episode in particular
is actually um sponsored by compass mining so
they're the company that makes bitcoin mining
accessible for everyone you just buy your machine
pick a hosting facility and let them do the work
so if you want you can start mining bitcoin and
you can just head to compassmining.io so if it
wasn't for them we wouldn't be able to do these
amazing podcasts okay so today we have a really
interesting guest joining me is the canadian
blogger influencer youtuber and podcaster it is
michaela peterson hey how you doing not too bad
thank you so much for having me on it's good to
finally meet you after following you on twitter
for a while yeah it's good to meet you too um i'm
a big fan of your father's you all the work that
you guys do um and yeah i've been really excited
to to have you on so this is gonna be good when
i yeah i'm excited so when i was going through
all the different topics that we could talk about
there is so much um and i wanted to start off by
talking more really just about your family your
background because unfortunately your family has
sort of just come into the limelight i feel like
out of nowhere um you know your dad went from um
you know canadian professor lecturer to this
suddenly political figure and you guys just
went into the limelight so i just wanted to
understand you know how that's been and what
your upbringing was like having a father like like
jordan and jordan peterson sounds kind of weird to
say to you um but go on it'd be really interesting
to hear okay well it was pretty out of the blue
um for dad but at least for like for me and
making a podcast i kind of you know no i wouldn't
say jumped on that exactly but i took advantage
of the opportunities that presented themselves
so i um i took over dad's kind of social
media i didn't take it over he ran his youtube
but i was like hey you should be on instagram you
should be on facebook people will know you and
you know other on other platforms so i kind of
helped him grow that but it was pretty stressful
it's been pretty stressful the whole time and
there's so many good things that come of having
as an online following but if it's super wrapped
up in controversy like it has been with dad it's
been really stressful and i think for somebody
his age as well it was harder for him like
for me well you you're just more resilient when
you're younger right and i kind of grew up with
the internet and even though social media was a
little bit late like i didn't have that as a kid
but it's still easy to wrap my head around and
the whole situation has been so absurd for my
dad that has been like much harder for him and
stressful you know worried about losing his job
worried about what would happen like if you
end up in huge newspapers or huge magazines
people calling you you know an alt-right you know
horrible human being it's like what are people
gonna think of me and that amount of stress
has been very very very damaging to my family
like so i've been you know just what i've grown
for myself with a podcast and online following
that's been okay i can handle that but the
controversy that my dad has experienced has been
too much i would say it's been a lot so we live
in a world we lit yeah firstly i'm so sorry to
hear you know we live in a world where these
words are just thrown around alt-right racist
um you know white supremacists and how how
then as a family are you able to deal with
those accusations because i think it's concerning
because eventually these words will lose meaning
and lose value oh for sure i mean you throw yeah i
mean particularly the word racist is thrown around
in so many ways that don't actually mean racist
that yeah you do lose the word and it's actually
a really important word to have so that's silly
but how like as a family how are we dealing with
it i kind of think well i don't know like i said
i've i think probably because i grew up with the
internet and kind of kind of understood the i
don't know just people online and trolls and
was like yeah it doesn't really matter like if
someone prints something about you it doesn't
really matter it does matter and it does cause
enough stress that people like it ruins people's
lives right people can be get taken down by the
mob or cancelled they end up committing suicide
like it can actually get really really bad um and
i think it's probably harder for older people who
well i don't know i can't even only blame it on
age because obviously it was more impacting his
direct character than it has been for me but i
think it has something to do with age and just
the absurdity of the whole situation yeah i think
you know because we're this age where millennials
we're sort of i know we haven't necessarily
grown up with this level of social media but
certainly like you said more resilient um yeah i
think yeah no i i i can appreciate that and i mean
i couldn't imagine my dad sort of receiving the
same kind of the same the same how do i put it um
controversy you know i just i couldn't imagine
it it must be tough um but you know this this new
world like i'd love to hear your opinion on where
you think we're going you know there are so many
things that we're not allowed to say anymore and
things that we're not allowed to discuss i mean
it'll be really interesting to talk about
covert and things like that especially because
just now the news has just come in so this
is really cool to talk to you about it
that um in the uk they'll be implementing
vaccine passports for clubs and bars um
so yeah in terms of what you can and can't
say you know where do you sound on that
i don't know what's gonna happen like i've
been pretty pessimistic about the whole thing
yeah i i wasn't in canada
for like four months because
i was you know i don't want to live here it's
scary downtown is empty everyone's walking around
fearful and i'm back now but people are still
fearful things are slowly opening up uh i'm
i'm sure that they'll i'm not sure i'm pr fairly
certain that they're going to implement some sort
of vaccine passport uh and i don't know how things
are gonna go i mean it's interesting because we
have the social media and we're able to have
jobs online and everything kind of went remote
that people i think people will end up moving to
places that they wouldn't have normally moved to
like i was in belgrade for a while that was
amazing croatia is pretty nice i don't know
what covid laws are going to be like in those
places and they might be just as strict i'm
not sure but at least they don't have this kind of
for lack of a better word liberal undertone that's
freedom of speech so so there's two problems
going on there's the oh things are going in a
bit of a weird direction with freedom of speech
and you know certain terms that are being thrown
around like racist white supremacists whatever but
then on top of that we have the covid restriction
problem and so i don't know i think some people
are going to end up moving i mean you can see
what's happened in the u.s where people are like
well i guess la isn't the place to be anymore yeah
so that must just continue the uk is interesting
it's interesting that they implemented that
because from what i know about the number of
people vaccinated is most people who are going
to nightclubs the younger like generation
haven't even had time to get more than one
well no so so they're not implementing it
until the end of september to give people time
to force right do it faster yeah yeah but the
thing is my my thing with it is and i actually
just tweeted about this is that for me it's so
obvious that it's not a good thing like forcing
someone to put a foreign substance in their body
to me it's just so obviously not a good thing
yeah well it's not it's not really that though
is it it's not really whether it's been tested
it's kind of just it's just medical coercion
i feel like people should be free to choose
well yeah i i do too but i mostly do because
well i don't trust the medical system very much
okay um and i i i just had covet i just got
over yes i was gonna ask you about that in
moscow yeah so that's the second time
i've had it and it was it was bad enough
and i put i put a video out because i've been
pretty vocal vocally like against lockdowns and
suspicious of everything and i put a video
out saying you know if this specific covid
situation doesn't end for the next number of
years like if this is just a virus that's around
and the vaccine turns out to help and not have
any serious side effects for young younger people
i'll probably consider getting it later as much
fun as having covid once a year is because the
last time i had it i was and i'm pretty healthy
but i still have like this morning i woke up
i have a slight wheeze i'm covered negative i
haven't had hovid for like weeks now but i still
have a slight wheeze and i'm i'm pretty healthy
so i don't know yes i'm against the government
forcing anybody to pretty much do anything because
i don't think anyone can tell a whole bunch of
people what to do with any sort of intelligence
um so you are and your vote so you're you're
vocally against lockdowns can you tell me more
about that because for some people it's so hard
just to it's so hard just to be like go on go for
it yeah go look at you like getting comfortable
man so i've been vocally against that since you
know we i was in florida when covet hit and then
i think may after covet hit i was like okay this
lockdown thing is not going to be a good idea
and i feel like if you had half a brain you could
figure out why it wasn't going to be a good idea
that wasn't going to be a good idea because there
are going to be people who don't have any money
who are going to get very unstable um every time
people lose jobs there's an increase in the death
rate suicides go up overdoses when people are
stressed out and i was like well how is how is
the government going to be able to monitor all
the kind of secondary deaths due to a lockdown
and compare it to covid and now this the
data is finally coming out after it's been
i don't know how how long has it how long
have you been has it been like 18 months
well it started it came in march 2017 yeah yeah
so it's been a while um but some of the data some
of the data is coming out and at least in where
did i just shared something i can't remember if
it was from the us or canada but the even just
the number of overdoses that have increased in
the last year in young people have killed
more people than kovit has so that's just
one factor that's just overdoses and that's young
people so we're locking everything down to save
people who are above 80 without even asking
them if they're okay with it like hey how
about you you don't see your family for a year
and also you make your grandchildren depressed
and potentially suicidal and you you don't have a
choice because it's for your own good like i don't
know no you make that you make such an interesting
point because no you're exactly right because it
does disproportionately affect young people and
a lot of people 80 plus share that exact opinion
i was talking about this with my grandfather
he's like 93 and um despite the lockdowns we
live in different parts of the country like
a three-hour drive and despite the lockdowns
i still went to see him he still wanted me to go
see him of course because he's old yeah what else
are you gonna do i know and i went to i actually
went to go fill his fridge for him and i'd posted
it so i'm quite um vocal about what i'm doing and
i always go fill his fridge bless him you know
put some nice meat in there so he was all sorted
for the winter and um people were criticizing me
and i thought my grandfather needs to eat and
he's 93. like you need to mind your own business
and unfortunately nobody's able to mind their own
business nowadays and i feel like we're all sort
of told yeah say that again sorry well i don't
know how much social media has to do with that
i don't know if this would have been happening
the same way if we didn't have social media and
we couldn't see everything like into everybody's
lives it might have been completely different wow
yeah it heightens it so it heightens all the
fear because things spread easily right but
also people are actually able to move
their jobs to their home more than they
would have before so we actually had
the ability to work from home which
you thought would be a good thing but it
turns out it just shut everything down
so it's tricky yeah it's a very strange world
we live in and another topic i really wanted to
discuss with you um was good old feminism um and
i'd love to know your stance on it and the main
question i have for you really is do you think
modern day feminism has a place in today's society
i've been doing a lot of like research kind
of so i have a daughter she's almost four and
i've been trying to learn more about like
my own i guess psychology because i can see
some of the things that i don't like in myself
showing up in her because they you know kids
so i'll do something that i'm kind of not aware
of you know maybe get resentful about something
just something like that and then i she'll kind
of display it and i'll be like oh my god so i
i actually have to fix that so it doesn't pass
on so wait you have to give me an example i don't
understand you have to give an example well okay
say i'm upset about something like say something
stressful happens and i'm upset about it if i
don't actually like healthily express that emotion
and try and get it out if i'm just like okay
everything's fine i'll just like hold this in
until later when i'm by myself or something
she gets obviously you can feel that kind of
energy when you're around people right if you're
around someone who's upset and they're pretending
everything's okay everybody can feel that but
i've been so that's what i mean once you have kids
you know if you're around other adults they can
all pretend that nothing's happening but when you
have kids they'll start displaying like emotions
that you're like pent up holding so when that
started happening and i'm like i've been through a
number of stressful things like especially in the
last couple of years so she's been around a lot
of stress so i've been trying to figure out how to
helpfully deal with that bring that back to
feminism i think i think recently things got
a little bit confused because there are ways to
you know there are certain things that need to be
talked about the way that we're handling it now
and that modern day feminism is handling it now
isn't healthy which is too bad because i
think it's the you know feminists started
on the right foot i think yes to try
and say you know you know women need
these things maybe women are different people
maybe being a mom isn't so bad like it it started
in kind of a a different universe and it ended
up here where there's you know toxic masculinity
which even just saying that kind of thing is
making the problem you're trying to solve worse
yes so what do i think about it i think that
people need to be more educated in like terms
like codependency and i just had this was really
interesting actually do you know the book uh
no more mr nice guy it's by this guy it sounds
really familiar yeah it's a bestselling book i'd
heard of it too but i just talked to him on my
podcast dr robert glover and he's one of these
like men's group not therapists for lack of
a better word he's a doctor but right um we
talked a lot about how you know childhood
trauma can manifest in different ways as a
man when you're older as a woman as you're when
you're older and having conversations like that
is it's just different than saying hey men are
evil which doesn't help anybody so i don't know
this like i told you earlier i'm a little bit
pessimistic about the state i think lots of people
are a little bit pessimistic i'm pessimistic i'm
pessimistic because i'm unfortunate but uh like
canada i don't know how canada is gonna turn out
i'm hoping that it'll be able to recover from this
but there's a number of things that are going
wrong like i said not just covid but also the
i don't know liberal movement i
don't even know what to call it the
call it the liberal movement even though they're
not all for freedom and like what liberal really
means we can we understand we get it it's been
hijacked like that yeah so that's happening i
don't know if canada's gonna make it i don't
know if i'm considering moving to the states
i'd love to move to austin or you know somewhere
like that but i don't know how many wait just
is that difficult as a canadian i have a not
really i think i can get an 01 and i have a second
visa like if they go there and live there for
six months they're not allowed to work though
so i i'd have to deal with a visa which but i
think i can get an 0-1 so fortunately i don't
think it would be that hard but i don't
even don't even know how how long some
of those cities are going to be okay for or
whether they're going to be like taken over by
postmodern liberals i don't know like i don't have
words for them no i understand and like you know
just just back to the the feminism topic there's
so much going on it that we're not allowed to
talk about which is why i love doing this podcast
because we can say what we want um within reason
and right now you know we have the olympics
and we saw there's a trans woman um who i
believe beats some i think she won right
well she won she won as a weightlifter so
my thing is it's really simple each to
their own right but i really feel that
modern-day feminism just isn't pro-women like
for me i can't understand how that's pro-women
i i completely i completely agree i do not
know how this happened that didn't happen
it's weird that you put the you put the right
wing conservatives in the group that are like
more pro-women it just yes it's upside down
right now it's very it's very strange where are
you right now are you still in the uk yeah i'm
in the uk um today is called freedom day um so
it's the day that our restrictions have lifted um
but i don't plan to stay here like i said they're
bringing in vaccines freedom day yeah yeah both
sides are uncomfortable with that why does that
make you shiver oh that's so creepy yeah we'll go
online well why would they name it freedom rather
than something that has to do with covid like if
okay if kobit restrictions are being lifted then
call it something that has to do with that not
like now you're free again like what yeah i mean
so both sides are uncomfortable with it so let's
just say people that are pro lock down don't like
it because now it sounds like this is about um
authoritarianism rather than like uh medicine and
health and public health and things like that so
they don't they think that that's propaganda right
so they're just like no you're distracted from
the narrative this isn't about authoritarianism
this is about health but then the people who
are against it yeah and then the people who are
against it also feel i don't i don't know it's
a creepy day but to be honest it's something to
do with authoritarianism well yeah because it's
like that if you're trying to get away from that
like storyline i guess it's too i decided that
i don't know i guess it's probably been decided
i don't actually know the prime minister
uses the term freedom day um it's a pretty
to me it's a great name i think it's a great
name i because it literally describes what's
happened it literally describes it no it does
it definitely does it's just if you were in the
this is why i don't trust the government it's like
if you were trying to weave some sort of storyline
that was against this right-wing
authoritarian plot why would you
name the day freedom day how can you mess up
that badly it was probably like an 18 year old
working in an office somewhere and they're like
we need a name you didn't come up with a name
no what about freedom day yeah okay good enough
whatever no one's going to pay attention anyway
yeah well you know that's politics for you and and
that's the government for you but um no i i do i
do want to delve a bit more into your opinion on
feminism these days um because it isn't pro women
and i don't know whether um you think we could
ever get to a point where things could sort of
reach a nice equilibrium you use
the time toxic masculinity earlier
um i think it's a stupid time you know if you're
trying to have a conversation with someone
you can't insult them back you know um so do you
think we'll ever get to that equilibrium i don't
think the trajectory we're headed on right now
is is heading in any sort of equilibrium universe
so are we going to get so what do we do i don't
know it's tricky i've been so i get fed up with
how things are looking here and then i'll go
somewhere like okay i'll go to eastern europe
right it doesn't have the same problems other than
covet it doesn't have it has different problems
though right so you go there and you're like oh
[ __ ] you know the north american infrastructure
which is something everyone here takes for granted
including me is actually incredibly well set up
like it's amazing that the society functions this
well and i went to i was in russia for a while
and a couple of other places but there are
basic things there that are missing because
north america is really well set up
and people here are forgetting it so
like i said i don't think it's heading in a
good direction but i don't know where else to go
i don't think that i feel the same sentiment it
doesn't it's fine it's fine because your sentiment
your sentiment says enough it's completely
fine but you spoke about earlier you know
making money online and at least that's something
that we can do um and you know you've got a super
successful podcast amazing guests so how do you
how do you do that balance all this stuff going on
in your personal life like we spoke about earlier
this increasing authoritarian world you know
you're really building something for yourself so
from like an entrepreneurial standpoint then you
know like how do you how do you go about that
how do you deal with that well i'm i'm really
happy with how things have turned out in my work
life like the podcast is unbelievably successful
i still can't believe people watch it like that
really it really surprises me uh and people seem
to say yes when i ask them to come on so and
i've learned enough about social media that
well i've managed to like delegate some tasks so
i'm not doing everything myself anymore which is
also a relief so i've i'm set up really well work
wise uh i don't know how to balance that properly
with the rest of my life like i i do end up but
you do i don't i do sometimes i'm doing a podcast
doesn't mean everything else is well organized
the podcast is well organized i'm still well
that's new certain that's news to the outside
world yeah yeah what would you say okay fine
so what would you say some of like the three main
things are to building a successful podcast then
consistency um so i mean i had a i had a head
start because people know my dad my dad has a
podcast i already had a social media following
so if you already have a social media following
then things are going to be easier for
you obviously yeah but i would say if
you don't have a social media following and
you want to start one it would be consistency
and i know i know some people who've had podcasts
for a long time and they had like hardly any views
hardly any views for a really long time and
then it was kind of like a pareto distribution
of viewers so i would say consistency don't talk
all the time when you have a guest on like people
are going to get bored of your podcast really
quickly if it's just you talking all the time
unless maybe you're tim dylan or a comedian
so that doesn't that's not the same for
everyone but most people aren't very funny so
don't talk too much especially if you're not
a popular comedian uh so let's see
consistency don't talk over the ghast
and then i guess the other thing would
it's pretty this is this is pretty easy
but make sure you post it everywhere like have
a youtube channel have an instagram channel use
tick talk use twitter like don't don't think
that you're better than one platform when tick
tock came along a lot of people were like oh
you know tick tock is full of like dancing you
know half naked women i'm not going on tick tock
but when youtube started it was all cat videos
so you just don't don't think you're better than a
social media platform and use all of them because
it's better to put your stuff up somewhere and
not have it watched than to miss out on one of
the big platforms so yeah consistency don't talk
over the guest and use social media properly
yeah take talk is a huge honor totally
right when that first came about people
would i was posting videos on there
and everyone was sort of laughing and
i was like no trust me this is good this is good
i see um clips from your dad on there all the time
all the time it's it's so amazing
it's it's honestly brilliant um
intellectual content like yeah is making
its way on there oh yeah it's not there yeah
so it's it's worth it uh i find it i find it
very interesting and i know it's this like evil
chinese company but it's so good at like if
i actually spend some time on there and like
videos i spend some time just to figure it
out and like videos that i like the algorithm
is amazing it'll amazingly yeah it'll
instantly show me what i like or if i don't
interact with it enough it'll show me what it
thinks i like so i've been getting like i'm not
that like if politically i'm libertarian like
through and through i'm not super conservative
oh i think you're i think your camera has frozen
hang on let me see if it's me that's gone or
you that's gone guys can you tell me if i've
frozen or if michaela has frozen let me know
in the comments if it's me or michaela
cause i'm not sure let's have a look
maybe if i i'm good okay so michaela's frozen
all right let's see if we can get her back
let's see if we can get her back
oh wow her power went out okay guys
her power went out that is crazy yeah
her power went out all right let me see
how quickly we can get her back in okay
let me see if we can get her back in see this is
honestly live that's what happens when you go live
let's see if i remove her okay now it's just
me all right well why would we wait for mikaela
to come back in yeah she's coming back in
okay well why wait for her to come back in
um i'm gonna give a quick shout out to my
sponsors because guys without my sponsors we
just wouldn't be here so shout out to blockfy um
i left a little um i left a link for you guys you
can get amazing interest rates and 250 when
you sign up and actually my newest sponsors
this month um is compass mining so they are the
company that makes bitcoin mining accessible for
everyone um you can just get a machine pick
a hosting facility and let them do the work
which is pretty cool because if you think about
it mining bitcoin is so difficult right now so
compass mining i'm making it super easy for
everyone let's see how michaela is doing
okay while we wait for michaela guys if you have
any questions i'm gonna take this opportunity
to do an ama while we wait for michaela
so feel free to leave your questions so
i said trudeau is listening that's really funny
um is that why the power went out all right i'm
gonna leave this opportunity i'm gonna take
this opportunity to am i british or australian
i feel like it's kind of obvious isn't it i'm
british but you know what's really really funny as
we were talking about um as we were talking about
tick tock her power went out it's kind of crazy
all right let's see what else if she is coming
in guys i'm going to take this opportunity to do
a ama so feel free to leave your feel free to
leave your questions all right i'm having a look
at that okay all right so michaela has just said
that she can't her power's not coming back on that
is crazy okay so guys i guess we won't be able
to continue that's a shame i wanted to ask her
about bitcoin um i think we were still gonna
go for another 20 minutes um but i will stay
on for another five minutes you guys are welcome
to ask any questions because obviously i want to
make this a great podcast for everyone so feel
free to throw any questions in i'm gonna go
up now and actually have a look at some of the
comments that came through um someone says they
always like to watch that's very nice let's have
a look leia remembers march bitcoin dip of course
i remember the bitcoin dip in march um let's have
a look what are my thoughts on xrp i really don't
have any major thoughts on xrp i know everybody
seems to think that i do but i i really don't um
will bitcoin continue to go down it's impossible
to predict this kind of market um all you can do
is hold i haven't sold any bitcoin i'm also
really vocal about the fact that i actually
get paid in bitcoin so i was getting paid when
bitcoin was at its all-time high at 60 000
and i decided not to sell of course i'm not
gonna sell like why would i sell i'll take a 50
hit so no i'm i'm happy to hold um even if bitcoin
goes back goes down it will go back up so i'm not
i'm not overly concerned all right i'm gonna
continue to answer just a few more questions um
somebody said either michaela froze or she's
the best statue that's funny no she furries
unfortunately why do you think france
is threatening jail time for not having
vaccine passports but the uk just lifted all
restrictions so actually the uk has just lifted
all restrictions but that doesn't necessarily mean
it's a good thing because they actually announced
today that they're gonna be um implementing
vaccine passports for nightclubs and large
events at the end of september um so this isn't uh
this isn't necessarily a good thing for me this is
unbelievable it's medical coercion but
i've spoken about that i'm not gonna
continue to go on about it all right i'm
gonna answer one more question i see some
conspiracy theories in the comments that's
that's good fun i'm gonna answer one more
question we'll look through your questions now
and then we'll we'll call it a day on today's
podcast you're welcome for a response more than
welcome okay i'm gonna answer one more question
okay where am i going in the us okay so once
my book is done um i do hope to get to the us
that will be so actually i was talking about
this today so my book was set to launch at the
end of july and um it probably will launch at the
end of july um but we are delayed a little bit so
for those who don't know i've written a book
about bitcoin it's called undressing bitcoin
and the goal of this really is to make
bitcoin accessible for everyone i find that
the it's quite a difficult and complex and
sophisticated topic and i really wanted to
just make it fun like i want to make it
fun lots of flavor taste excitement and
i initially started writing this as a guide it
was initially a guide that was the whole goal
and as i started writing i was getting more and
more excited and i was getting really excited
by all the um the philosophy behind bitcoin you
know when we talk about freedom decentralization
um bitcoin has a humanitarian solution to all
the tragedies that's going on in this world
um so i ended up turning this guide into a book
but it was heavy and there was so much in there
you know like when you love a topic you end up
putting so much into it um so it was just too
much unfortunately um fortunately my brother and i
were actually in the same country at the same time
we've both been traveling he's been traveling
but we're in the same country at the same time
and um i showed him the book and he was like
it's good but i think it should be a little bit
more like this and so honestly i'm taking this
opportunity to rewrite quite a lot of things
um i've cut down a lot for example i'll give
you full disclosure full examples um the first
chapter is the first chapter is the death of fiat
okay and in that chapter i spoke a lot about the
financial crisis mainly the 2008 financial crisis
mainly because bitcoin was largely born out of it
and um i spoke too much about it and i
think it's boring so i decided to delete it
like i've deleted like 15 pages of this book so
far so i decided to delete it because it's boring
and i want to keep it as concise and as
fun as possible there are some memes in
the book because memes are good memes are
exciting so there's some means in the book um
but yeah overall that was the goal and it did
really start off actually as a guide that's what
happened um and it was a guide that i was going
to sell by myself um but no i i i just got really
carried away i couldn't really carry away with
bitcoin as this humanitarian solution um you know
and yeah i'm excited i'm really really excited
so essentially when that's done um i will then
go to the states to answer your question so i do
want to go to the states i will go to the states
um somebody says my my connection is breaking up
i don't think it is i feel like i have a really
good connection you guys can let me know if it's
breaking up um but yeah i do want to go to the
states but i'm gonna finish my book first so i
actually finished writing it three weeks ago but
like i said my brother and i are actually going
through it now and just adding more spice and more
flavor to it um i'm just reading i'm reading all
the comments as you guys are talking to me that's
like talking this is really weird to multitask i
did this the other day actually um yeah so once
the book is written which um should be well once
the book is re-edited it's quite a heavy edit that
we're doing i will um do an audio version and um
that audio version will be available so it'll be
totally available on amazon you can buy the kindle
version the paperback oh and then what i'll do
is when i walk when i do go to the states because
most of you guys are um based in america so once i
do go to the states i'll probably do a meet-up and
a book launch um so yeah we can all meet we can
i can sign the books or whatever because i can't
actually send you signed copies because i'm doing
it through amazon but i'll definitely do a meet-up
so i'll let you guys know when that's happening
um okay i think i think that is all guys
um unfortunately michaela couldn't stay um
she had a power cut guys never forget the
power cut happened when we were talking about
tick tock i just i don't think i'll ever get
over that we were talking about d platforming
freedom of speech tick-tock china things you
can and can't say five very controversial topics
in today's world and um her power cut out quite
unbelievable all right guys well thank you so much
um for tuning in and for your comments and thank
you for hanging out with me while um michaela left
unfortunately but we'll definitely get that back
up i actually have another podcast this week
really really exciting so tune in for that um it's
with um a guy who's based in nigeria so you know
ah i'm still here i was gonna end this but just
last thing i'll say you know how i was saying
um how bitcoin is this humanitarian solution and
all that well i'm going to be speaking with a
guy who uses bitcoin and he's based in nigeria
i'm super excited if you didn't know i believe
in nigeria don't quote me on this but i'm more
or less right um there's a limit of a hundred
dollars a day you're allowed to make for like
international payments um it's just unbelievable
the restrictions in nigeria um and what's
happening happening with their central bank
um so yeah guys definitely tune in i think it's on
thursday um subscribe to my youtube so you don't
miss it you'll get a notification when um i go
live and then that's it all right guys i'm gonna
go now and need to find how i need to find the um
i have a little jingle that i play when i leave
so all right i'm going to play it now alright
guys thanks so much i'll speak to you all soon bye